now it's my pleasure to welcome Tatyana
Bilbao as the 23rd Louis icon visiting
assistant professor professor Bilbao
follows dan wood who occupied the chair
in the spring of 2014 and Risa gray and
Alma nor ganske who work on visiting
assistant professors in the last fall
term the Khan visiting assistant
professorship brings young architect
educators to our school offering them
the opportunity to lead an advanced
studio and if they wish a seminar
Tatiana Bilbao graduated in architecture
and urbanism from the Universidad
ibero-american ibero-american in 1996
from 1998 to 1999 she was an advisor for
urban projects at the Urban Housing and
Development Office of Mexico City
professor Bilbao was a partner at the
Mexico City based firm LCM in 2004 she
founded M xdf I'm going to take a
special course and what all these
letters mean together with Derek Dylan
camp
Arturo Ortiz and michael roark end MX DF
was intended as an urban research center
for the production of space its
occupation its defense and control in
Mexico City but as Professor Cavallo
shared because all the architects
involved are so busy with their own
offices these days the research center
is and I quote sleeping all right
Tatjana bilbao's own busy office which
is definitely not sleeping was this also
established in 2004 as an
interdisciplinary practice that develops
projects of architecture interiors and
urbanism in Mexico China and Europe in
2007 the practice is one of the top ten
of architectural records annual design
design Vanguard series survey in 2010
but Bilbao was selected as one of the
architectural League of New York's
emerging voices a distinction she shares
with the Past terms Khan visiting
assistant professors Lisa gray and Allen
oginski were Reeve received that award
in 2009 she is also the recipient of the
2012 Quincy priests from Berlin in 2010
three projects from the Bilbao office
were acquired by the Sanwa George
Pompidou in Paris to be part of that
centers architectural permanent
collection in 2012 professor bill vows
work was presented in the exhibition
under construction at the architect or
gallery in Berlin Germany
earlier this year professor Bilbao was
awarded the global award for sustainable
architecture by the locus foundation of
the cicada architecture of Paris and
through the patronage of UNESCO prior to
our tournament Yale professor Bill Val
has taught at her alma mater as well as
at the andres bello university in
Santiago de Chile and at the Peter
Behrens School of Architecture in
Dusseldorf Germany it's been a pleasure
to have tousle Tatiana Bilbao among us
this term her presence in the studio and
the seminar room has helped us Riaan
reaffirm the humanistic basis of
architecture as a method of
communication that as she recently
stated architecture does its best when
it is and I quote direct simple and
straightforward
please join me in welcoming the spring
2015 Khan visiting assistant professor
Tatiana Bilbao as she delivers the
lecture lessons lesson from two
gardeners Tatiana
thank you thank you professor Stern I'm
very very honored to be here I'm really
having an incredible time ideal this
semester so for the visiting really
don't go to Cambridge this is a school
I'm now the biggest fan of the school I
truly say these the students are great
the faculty is amazing but Professor
Dean makes it all just an incredible
experience the water is okay by the way
and I truly enjoy better the weather in
Mexico but the rest is really fine here
I will I will pro show some projects
that I think are a selection of a
description a clear description of the
ethics of the of what we do and what we
believe as architecture and I will start
saying that we started producing
architecture
I studied when when parametric
architecture was the way to go I mean I
didn't have a professor like right
leaner or none I wish I did
I really had I had I was when these
product or professor Eisenman even would
have been much better but we had like
even a very I would say an illogical way
of understanding parametric architecture
and when at the end way I translated
that in into into a work was trying to
understand different geometries with the
means I had we're not a very
technological country and I'm not a very
technological person and and so I didn't
have the means around me but I didn't
have the means all inside me I was not
educated in a very technological way so
I was starting to do architecture and
more analogically and more with my hands
more as the architecture I believe with
but I was still trying to to look for
entire uncharted geometries so I did
several projects going in that direction
exploring different geometries this
project is of a house in a in a hillside
in Monterrey in a the second-largest
city of Mexico and the client wanted up
how's of float a flat house one floor of
her house and but he showed me the the
site and I said well it's clearly
difficult to do one floor have house
that large he wanted it was a big
problem program in a hill like that so I
thought why don't we create a structure
that it becomes a fluid fluid space as
he wanted but it had that's a little bit
too the topography so what we did we
started working with a with an with a
Pentagon that adapts to that that
multiplies defines every space so every
room it's a different it's a different
form it adapts to the topography adapts
to the trees and becomes a house that
becomes a little bit more fluid than
having a one thought plows but not it's
not a house that it has two floors or
three floors in a row so what we did is
we accommodated all the public space
like lay lying down the the hill and we
wanted to have like the rooms more the
private part of the house attached to
the hill a little bit like hanging from
the hill and and this way as I said you
can follow from the living rooms from
the living rooms up to the top rooms
going up one or two steps so as I said
we were studying a little bit that
geometry going around and in identifying
how we could manage the Pentagon
adapting to them to the nature and to
the obviously to the program and and to
build it as a house and then we started
working in a project that was an amazing
challenge for us that we're still
working on ended we started working in
2005 so it's been almost 10 years that
we've worked in it it's a botanical
garden it's in Culiacan Culiacan is a
city in the north of the country so what
you see as a red dot is Mexico City and
Culiacan is on the north west coast and
Culiacan is a very regular City if you
co received
as easy as in an aerial photograph so
it's a city that has the same areas as
any city in Mexico to floor height
it's very extended but this city has a
particularities it's the city where the
drugs cartels were born so from all of
us in Mexico in our minds this city it's
really like the capital of the clocks
although the city is very safe the the
image we have the cities about people in
guns and drug dealing and these things
it's pretty safe because all the most
powerful capitals are from this city and
obviously they want to keep it safe
their families are there the friends are
there and they obviously they don't want
a city that makes a big buzz for the for
the police or for the military so they
can keep it calm safe and they can live
in peace so but in the other hand it
also has as well because it's very very
wealthy with bad money or illegal money
it is very wealthy also because it has
several businesses that had become
international and transnational like
this retail company named couple and the
president of this company is very proud
of this city and he's the president of
the board of this Botanical Garden and
he decided to donated pieces of his
collection to this garden this garland
exists there since 235 years as I said
the president of the board is these very
important businessmen from well from
from Culiacan and that wants to be to
make his city a city that it's
remembered by for different things and
not just because of the drug dealers so
he decided he's also an incredible art
collector who sue so he decided to
donate a piece of his collection to the
garden and he decided by doing so to
hire a curator a very important curator
who's now the director of who makes
collection who someone might my heard of
it the David Chipperfield Museum in
Mexico City and so the curator is a very
important person in Mexico and who
advised him to
- what pieces to put in the garden so
first they were discussing what pieces
to put in the garden and then Patrick
comes with this idea of instead of
donating pieces of the collection of
coupling the garden to Commission the
artists of his collection to do a
site-specific work so that the project
became very ambitious and then they
invited all they decided they needed an
architect to understand the place to
really work with the artist to
understand how the pieces could be
inserted in this landscape and how the
project could become more reasonable by
building spaces like a library and
exhibition room etc so we were hired and
when we went there and we saw like how
the life of the garden was really an
important one for the city not only for
the educational purposes but also for
recreational ones and also a very
representative one because people are
the girls when they turn 15 they go
there to take their their own
photographs in this setting so as you
can say it's an eco name in the city
it's a place where people recognize as
part of the city as for important part
of the city as a place where they they
really like to go in special occasions
so we decided to go there analyzed this
space and first obviously with our
architecture mind we said oh this place
a mess it was designed by a by an
industrial engineer that loved plants
and that convinced the government to
donate a piece of land so that he could
make his collection public and he said a
little by little adding at one path here
one other pad here and other building
there so when you when we are when I
arrived there I say oh my god what we're
gonna do with these we need to start
over and then and then I started meeting
the people there and I specially met
this guy Felipe who the UN Rica sorry
who is the gardener there and we started
understanding the stories behind the
garment and we understood the first very
important thing that we needed to to
find a way to insert these pieces there
and not to try to change the things
because the
the garden existed it was very very
rooted in the society and if we just
totally erased everything of that we
would have been a tempering on the
popularity of the place or also on the
good part of the place so what we did is
we trace the branches of a tree that
existing tree when I cast lay of the
garden and we just overlapped it with
well existed and the good part of it is
that with a with a with a scheme like
these we could adapt the scheme to
whatever it existed or to the new things
and it didn't matter because as being
branches you can move them and they
they're survival they can cut them
industry the tree could still grow so
that was our idea with the master plan
and we did we adapted and we proposed a
master plan in the beginning and my task
was to build to build some as I said
programmatic structures or pavilions
that could allow these new art that come
came in be understood know so I was to
do an auditorium a library all these
things I said and I said I need to break
them in little pavilions and spread them
all over the the garden many things that
we did we're little interventions little
things like these landscape thing so
when I enter I said well this needs to
be to remind us a very as a botanical
garden it it's it's very important that
if the collection is going to be as
important as as you are saying because
artists were going to range between
DIYing james terrell tank rahamallah for
aleeah's on all the big artists all the
big names you can imagine the I said the
the botanical collection is to be
reinforced and needs to become really an
important botanical garden so what I did
is invited a group of landscape ecology
of landscape this is what they call they
are what they call what they do and so
to do little intervention so that they
look little but they're big to reinforce
botanical collections to replace their
eye
that were of the species that were
affecting other ones to really enhance
the ecosystems and to do little moves in
the in the insertion of things like for
example they spawn around the bamboo
area and reinforced the bamboo
collection or put our logs to to really
enjoy the palm collection or only to
reinforce the edges but to leave the
activities just to flourish
in the beginning I thought perfect they
dude okay let's do it joke kiosk imagine
this would be beautiful in the middle of
the garden blah blah blah and then I was
talking to these and Enrique was around
and he said and what for and then I was
thinking yeah what for I'm gonna kill
the activity people just gonna feel
really not spontaneously to go there and
do a yoga so we'd really learn to just
do very small moves like to open the the
irrigation system so people can really
see it how it goes and it also makes a
beautiful experience open little paths
to see parts of the collection that
we're not there or insert little species
that could enhance the landscape but
also the collections and the same thing
the artists need the artists this is a
piece by a Loren Cassidy yeah Loren
Franz Xavier these are very too
important American artist that
represented America in the architecture
art Biennale two years ago three three
years ago and and they did this simple
beautiful piece that obviously is the
setting of many things in the garden no
but I wanted I this is a piece from for
from the Angra ham diagram came to the
garden it's part of the place obviously
very difficult to photograph but it B
has become now the frames of weddings so
what I what I really like about the the
whole thing in these botanical garden
and what we definitely didn't intended
it was that this has become an everyday
thing for the people the art has become
a discussion of the everyday and
and in Mexico this doesn't happen
especially in a city like willya can in
Culiacan there's no art at all point
zero no museums there's one little
museum that has no collection that has
some temporary shows if we were to have
the same budget we have by Augustine
with his collection and done a beautiful
white box totally insulated great light
incredible temperature control
temperature everything people who would
never have been there and people would
have never get involved in art and what
it's happening now which is incredible
is how people is really getting involved
with art in a very everyday life these
fees by Allah for Allah
Elias on just shows very suit in a
certain way how seasons do change in
this place because the weather is so so
hot that people normally think it's just
a horrible weather the whole year is so
hot but it doesn't it really changes and
it changes from spring summer fall
winter etc so these art which is a
beautiful form it just has a plan that
changes through the year and it it just
very subtly explains that or these piece
that it's a Richard long piece that was
this is the only artist that was
obviously never in the garden and in the
they are Augustine the procedure
envelope bought this place for this
Pacific which was normally in a public
space with a with a beautiful name tag
everything set up for the for the peas
nobody touch today nobody seeded it it
was in a public space but it makes in
Culiacan has become the picnic area and
this is great I mean for example these
pieces they're ASA Margolis is one of
the most controversial art artists in
Mexico he deals with the theme of drug
dealers he was a representative of
Mexico to the art Biennale in Venice
that the same three years ago and these
ventures are a set of vendors that are
done with concrete but poured with the
water that were used to wash that people
were there people from drug dealers so
it's a very strong piece and the idea of
the artist is that
people are resting in this thing the
society is resting in this problem not
saying anything and for a year the peace
was there without being announced that
this was done with these water the
artists always wanted to have the
announcement but we'd never had like
that there were technical problems in
the garden they couldn't do it and at
some point when they did it the people
was really really mad they were they
went to the press they went to the to
the government because this is a public
garden the public garden and it became a
big thing so then the garden decided to
invite the artists to give a lecture
then the artist gave a lecture and
finally these people became the first
fans of the artists and the first fans
of what is happening in the in in the
garden so actually people is getting
engaged with art in a very different way
as I'm saying and if this would have
been these same pieces would have been
in the museum nothing of these has had
happened
a piece from micro Round three a piece
of Attili release out and what we did is
we did a series of blue pavilions and
what we did and we're doing because
we're still on the way a set of little
pavilions that our idea is always to
remind you that you are in a Botanical
Garden so the first sex test we needed
to comply with a room for an
introduction of seven minutes for a
video introductory of the garden seven
minutes and we decided to create to
convince the everybody to do an open
structure so the introduction would be
giving in in an auditorium that's open
it was a difficult task because there
used to have this air-conditioning
building so they actually were imagining
a building like with four walls in a
roof with a screen with an air
conditioning and we said we need to open
it if you're gonna go in there and visit
for three hours you can sure sit for
seven minutes and see this introductory
video and if not you must find out in
the introduction then you won't want to
stay in this place
so so we did we only did a place that
it's open
ventures and a series of walls that
define the space so they can create also
a little hole of waiting holes so people
from the next tour can wait outside
so actually fulfilling the program but
in a different way and the same strategy
we did in all the buildings and we did
this as I said set of buildings that we
wanted to break in the lowest or in the
minimal possible way programmatically is
breaking them in the minimal possible
way to again make you feel always that
you're in a botanical garden so we did
say these three set of buildings in a
different location that are an
educational room for kids an auditorium
and a service area and they are all
spread out and the idea is that when you
are in the in the auditorium like here
you want to go to the toilet you need to
go outside you need to feel the the heat
normally the heat or the rain or the the
the birds singing or the or the leaves
we're singing because of the wind
whatever you need to feel that you're in
the middle of a botanical garden so we
did these three structures or these
pavilions that relate to each other
depending on the from the use obviously
for a function uses and we repeat the
scheme several times so this is the way
we are adding pavilions in the whole
garden art is some artists have also
decided to relate to our buildings this
is the little bumps you see in front of
the buildings it there was an existing
little Hut for educational purposes in
the garden that we turned down and the
artist Erzurum Quinto decided to keep
the ruins and add them as a landscape or
a playground in front of our buildings
we also have a collaboration with other
ideas like Diana Teeter did a piece for
the interior of the of the auditorium or
even a news van there from Brazil did a
very nice piece for a chalkboard in the
interior of the educational room so a
big list of artists is working in the
garden but it also has
Architects were doing several more of
these little pavilions all over that
comprehended
an exhibition room a library now we're
building the storage the laboratory is
their volume and the greenhouse the
study a greenhouse not the public
greenhouse the offices in soon we will
start building the other buildings
cafeteria and some things this is a work
in progress another thing that I forgot
to say our ad in terms of how we define
the building aesthetically speaking it
was to use one so material that could
work aesthetically structurally for
insulation and for doing the whole
building so actually it's a shell that
it's a thirty centimeters wide so the
the slab that that is the support slab
and the walls and the roof is all thirty
centimeters thick of poured concrete and
it creates these little shells in the
set in the middle of them in the center
nothing is in it there's no structure
and the column you see here it supports
the mid level but it doesn't support the
roof so as I said they're little shells
that in our sense of seeing it they're
like little rugs that arrive to the
garden and to that can dialogue a little
bit with the nature also we want them to
at some point be even by the nature if
it's the case then another project that
we were developing at the same time and
it's really a contradiction we were
developing a place where life starts and
we were developing at the same time
where life ends so we were developing
this funeral house in San Luis Potosi
and I don't know much about funeral
houses here in the US but in Mexico
they're really Tetrick they're horrible
you feel there I think that even like if
you were dying because they're really
bad places they're horrible so we
decided to do a place that would if it
didn't if you didn't like the place at
least you would be so mad at it so it
will be
so dramatic that you should be mad at it
so you could forget a little bit about
your your-your-your moment the moment
you were having there no so what we
created if we wanted to do a place that
was dramatic as I said and changing in
light in many ways so what we did is a
main hole that had the five chapels
around normally in Mexico the funerals
are like the marine chapel it's
everything and then the holes are very
little and everybody is in the hole
because nobody wants to speak where
they're where the body is so they don't
go out so what we did is we created a
big hole that it's very by magnetic but
also inside of the chapels what we did
is we created a different idea of having
a small like living room and then the
mooring chapel and then a garden a
private garden so you can have like
three stages of privacy the garden is
being very private then they were their
bodies being more private than the
social area a little bit more public and
then the and then the hall so as I said
we wanted to be very dramatic and we
were you wanted to use a little bit to
relate to the place the place is San
Luis Potosi
it's in northeast part of Mexico between
Mexico City and Monterrey for those that
you know a little bit the Geographics of
Mexico and and so though it's very
desired to take the place but the place
has this aggregate that has this color
so we wanted to use the the aggregate
and what we did here we started
experimenting with the hand labor we
started understanding that our
architecture was still very hard to be
rooted in this place in Mexico so but
still what we did here is we knew that
the contractor was going to be the guy
that did the maintenance for the funeral
houses of these families that they'd
have more more of these businesses and
we knew that the guy doing the plumbing
the maintenance of every day was going
to be the contractor so we had we know
we knew that this was not going to be a
very
a skilled hand labor so we decided to to
understand what while what was their
capabilities we knew we wanted concrete
and we knew we wanted the aggregate of
the area so we did like thousand
mock-ups before we started even
designing to understand it and then we
understood that we had to define a space
that would be written off as readable as
the the space as this one and it didn't
matter if the finishes were not perfect
because the definition of our
architectures was going to be within the
entire definition of the space and not
the definition of the final detail
otherwise we would have been totally
frustrated because I said we need since
the beginning that these things were
going to happen and and so we did that
and we created the as I said these this
building with this hole we put it in an
exposed concrete that we did with this
aggregate of the area and that therefore
the color we created a for formwork that
it had these texture in order to not
hide but to enhance the idea of the of
the errors and then perfections and but
also in the interior we tried to treat
it as a very peaceful and beautiful
place but I think that the most
important lesson that I learned that I
already have started to learn in the in
the funeral house was building this
house and ironically enough this house
was not designed by me this house was an
idea of Gabriele Orozco who's one of the
most important contemporary artists I
don't know even know it it he's a
Mexican contemporary artist that it's
exposed in all over the world and he
decided it's a funny story I'm gonna
tell you a little bit because I think
students can learn from it when he we
had no work we went out of school we had
no work we were doing competitions
little
things for you know the garage of an
uncle and these little things and doing
competitions all over the world and we
said we need to do more fun things and
we were designing a house in the moon we
probably thought that we were going to
be designing houses at the moon and then
we decided to design a house for
Gabrielle Orozco who we admire his work
and and then we decided to show it to
him we didn't knew him but we found a
way to get to him we found him we knock
on his coat door we show him with the
design he laughs a lot obviously but he
liked it he liked the idea of three
three students out of school design a
hive for him he follow it a little bit
and five years after he arrives to my
office with a little model and knocking
on the door saying that you know you
need to help me so you never know who
you work for and so I obviously was an
incredible experience working for
Gabriel Orosco for three years with
Gabrielle Orozco for three years and
he's a little bit obsessive and we
learned so many things about it but I
think the most important thing that I
learned was from this little guy from
Philippe Philippe is the little lady the
leader of the community and now it has
become the house is here in the shore of
Oaxaca
this is Mexico City this is a shore of
Oaxaca so Philippe was the lid is a
literary of the Commission the community
is a fishing village and he now became
part of like the property manager and we
decided through him to hire the people
from the from the village to build a
house for many reasons and but basically
because it was the easiest thing but
obviously these people were not trained
lay the hand labor was absolutely not
trained they never had read a plan
forget I mean they they don't they don't
read they don't know how to read so we
met in a plant forget about it so all
the plans that we did for a year they
were in my drawer for the rest of the
construction and then we needed to
translate so what our task was it was to
translate this observatory that
Gabrielle wanted to put in in this place
that exists in India in
for men into a house and build it in
this place in this wonderful place so
it's a simple geometry it's a sphere
semi sphere and four rooms like actually
eight walls that support the semi sphere
and create the rooms and so I thought
it's pretty simple how simple can it be
to build it I thought it was a very
simple task it it turned out very
difficult obviously Mattern people not
knowing how to read to build this semi
sphere and but it was incredibly fun to
understand how willing these people were
how how creative they were although they
never have ever thought even of geometry
and the results were amazing so what I
really learned from here is that we
didn't need it to create and to still
searching about these Uncharted
geometries to create an incredible
contemporary dramatic space we could
work with geometry with pre-existing
geometry with the hand labor we have in
Mexico like as we did in in the funeral
house and still do contemporary
architecture in our country in our
context and much more rooted and that's
when I started to become I think more
honest with Who am I and with what my
architecture wanted to be and from then
we started doing so these operations of
understanding really what were the
skills of the people that were going to
build it and what were the conditions of
the of the project and the context I
totally believe that architecture is a
built environment and architecture in
many forms is and it's very useful to to
do it in a in a graphic way in a written
way but it is not completed as is it's
not a space so in this case for this
project we got a client that had a
budget of thousand dollars with a
program a very extended program of house
of three hundred square meters which is
three thousand square feet you know like
with the studio walking class said a
beautiful program then she left
left us with all these requirements and
I thought well we have to ask her to
double the budget or to decrease the
housing in half because it's not
possible the maths don't add and then I
thought we're not gonna build nothing if
we say that because she doesn't have the
double of the button and she ones the
houses size so why don't we find a
solution so so we decided to first
understand if there was a material that
would allow us to do that and we
understood that compacted earth rammed
earth would allow us to do it and so we
understood the use of the material we
understood how it worked we understood
how we could use it and the easiest way
to create these spaces so it would
obviously we didn't took the material to
the extreme so it wouldn't cost more in
order to fulfill the client needs and we
were able we finally decided to create
this structure that was based in the
module that the construction guy that
knew how to build this tab how to use
this technique knew and had because I
said if we wanted to experiment this
would have become more expensive so we
needed to go to the standards or at
least to the what the standards of the
things we had in hand and what we did is
we did that we we knew that he had a
mold that it was 6070 meters so we
needed to module the house in 60
centimeters all the way so we decided to
do two squares one that would contain
the public space one then we continued
the public space of the house one that
would continue that would have the more
private space of the house and then to
overlap the squares that would have all
the services and as you say as obvious
we needed to have a very simple finish
because we didn't have enough money to
do everything and so we used a ramp
there for everything you see there are
two columns they're the two drainage
main drainage tubes and everything was
done with the ramp earth and the
concrete slabs to make it cheaper at the
end these idea of working with this
client involving her with the idea of
sir doing a research for
and the material and then becoming the
material the director the director of
our design was an incredible process to
understand how important is to involve
the client she feels here really this is
her house now we're working with her for
another house for her permanent house
because he's a weekend house in what a
lahar a-- and and it's obviously because
we were very successful in in
understanding her needs and translated
them into a house so as I said we we
moved into working in a very geometric
way obviously trying to take geometry to
extremes but starting from geometry and
with this is the same way we did these
spectacles Center in Mexico it's called
Palenque but I was trying to find the
world it's more like a spectacle Center
with a special spectacle that it shows
in a Roman yet like theater so where the
artist goes in the middle so we decided
to create it as as a building that has
this structure that goes around this
scenario round scenario and round
seating area and we created the
balconies and we created these hallways
that allow people to that bring the
people from from the exterior to the
interior and to into the although
seating areas but also allow it for a
different program obviously it's a nod
to Frank's look right Guggenheim but we
wanted to understand these these rings
as something that could give something
else so the client houses were for a for
a cultural center spectacle Center and
that probably was going to be open for
60 days a year and it was in a rest and
a fair resident and what we decided is
to create these these these rings that
bring people in that become the
circulation but also become the activity
in the interior and the exterior so what
we did is we
the restaurants the bars in the stores
and these little things that they asked
us already in the program that they
bring when they came in but we allow we
create these rings that allow people to
go from the inside but also from the
exterior so this building could be used
also when when an event was not
happening I think also the architecture
has this that responsibility adding
something to to to the community I think
a building insert inserted in a
community that has a very important
impact and not thinking on that is
really not not my way of thinking of
architecture and for example this
building they wanted to create a
building that in a university in in
Culiacan in the same city of the
Botanical Garden that would be the link
between the the city and the campus and
the campus is gated and you can see the
gate there and in and in the beginning
they wanted to do the building inside
the campus and I say if we want to
create a building that it becomes the
the the link between the city and the
campus you need to bring the building to
the city otherwise it's not going to be
ever nothing so so we push them and we
push them to bring the the really the
building into the city we decided to
leave the program as they wanted they
were they wanted rectangle floors of a
thousand square meters that were
flexible enough to hold different types
of companies and we did that we only
just stack them in different ways so I
could create shadow four terraces and
for different purposes in a tear and but
the main thing as I said is that I do
believe that architecture can give
something else a little something else
and we also force them to create an
auditorium that could be used and rented
from the from any people in the society
so the building is actually part of the
society part of the public we are in in
Mexico the the universities and
technological campuses are all gated
communities mostly most all over them
so as I said we we started doing these
projects and right away from the
House of Gabriella Roscoe we did this
house that comes from a very
archetypical form of her house and these
design was for a project in China by a
crazy project in China over hundred
houses were done by a hundred different
architects this house was never built
but the idea of this house being
modulated in seven modules and create a
volume from us from the extraction of a
piece of each volume and I'm not going
to go into describe why we have actually
abstract one of each pieces gave gave us
the result as a building the answer as a
house that could be ventilated and
illuminated within its own volume but it
could also be very flexible and we got a
project in Mexico to design a house for
the lowest part of the pyramid which is
the people that don't even cannot even
get a loan from the workers bank which
is in front of it and these people have
really very low income normally no
formal jobs or no jobs at all and they
get these houses from the government
that are really horrible they cost for 8
from 5,000 to 8,000 dollars and we got
the task to design one of those so what
we did is first we started designing for
many many references we need all the
projects from an arena like autonomous
Sal and we'd looked for many other ones
I could touch every manatee Africa Avila
and then we we went him to starting
designing our own project and we decided
that we were designing for no one for
that we really needed to understand what
the people wanted and we went out and
did like 2,000 interviews and understand
two very important things that people
wanted a house that looked like the
house and the main reason was because in
Mexico since the set sixties there were
a lot of houses that were left built in
one floor with steel bars to the
exterior and - to be like grown up in
the future
and that they never did so in that
moment
that represented really like a sign of
ambition and of growing up and getting
more money but actually at their end
none of these houses or mostly none of
them got the second floor sold remained
with the steel bars on the top and these
become like a sign of failure so people
really didn't wanted to have a house
that was one floor flat because of that
that was the main reason so that's the
main reason why they wanted a house that
looked like the house and the second
thing they wanted is that they wanted
obviously I think that could be
expandable but if it didn't look to
finish the house they prefer to not have
the expansion to be possible I mean they
were willing to give away the expansion
so what we thought is what widening we
took our model we use for all those
because it allow us to had a module that
it was expandable but also he'll allow
us to build a part that it could be
built in a very strong material because
this is the second finding which we did
but they really want in a house that was
with strong material
they'd lame it with material and it's
like strong material and and the rest we
cut we could fill it with a different
material that would allow us to arrive
to the budget to begin a larger space I
like a house that can become expandable
but it didn't look like so we did the
main part of the house with a hard
material and the rest we could do it
with a material that would be more more
on permanent so in this case we wanted
to give more square meters in this case
we achieved to give more square the
notice square cubic meters for the same
amount of money and as I said we did it
in our model of orders adapting it doing
the the steady part with a with breaks
or panel and doing the rest with pallets
with industrial pallets and we did two
models a rural house and that has the
kitchen in the exterior because the
rural people have more of these
necessities also the modulation allow us
to be more adaptable to the commune
and to the climate and we did a suburban
house that has more modern idea of a
house of the having the bathroom inside
of the where the rooms are and the
kitchen integrated with the living area
and and we did two prototypes we build
them in Chiapas and soon they're now
going into the company that hires is
going into trauma two
to get the finance name of the
institution's she will become to give
these credits away and start building
right away we should be building this in
she says thousands but I don't know very
very new in a very near future the last
project I'm going to go through very
quickly it's a pilgrimage route we did
in in in Jalisco in the state of Jalisco
Jalisco is the state here this is Mexico
City whether la Jara which is the
capital of the state is the
third-largest
a more important city in New Mexico and
we were asked to do an intervention in
these people in my fruit of her that
it's around a hundred miles long but it
changes in altitude a lot so the
landscape is very different and three
million people walk through it during
Holy Week and Easter week so this week
three million people are working there
and the infrastructure they had was very
temporary and very non efficient
obviously with their all the villages
around really leave for these pilgrimage
and off from this pilgrimage and the the
neighbors and the people who live there
obviously offer the services to the
pilgrims that they the government
obviously doesn't offer the same
pilgrims do their own constructions
there in the mountain like this one
which is a little chapel and a little
sitting and resting place and it's
really a truly important pilgrimage for
for these people and what we decided is
that it was such a big project to do it
ourselves and I do we live in that
architecture needs much more than one
mind to become an important
thing especially in a project like that
so what we did is we I invited Derrick
Villa come to do the master plan with
another Mexican architect and together
we create a master plan and we decided
to invited architects from different
parts of the world we might at AI weiwei
from China we invited Alejandro Aravena
from Chile and we invited Kristen
Grantham in from Switzerland a THF also
from Switzerland and what we did is we
did a master plan with the government to
understand where we could do
interventions where we could put medical
services sanitary services trash
containers places to eat places to rest
water supply etc and and then where we
could put these places of worship of
veneration of rest of points of interest
and these are the points where we
convinced the government to invite
different architects obviously the
government say come on I hired one
architect now you want me to deal with
ten this is no way so have we said no
don't worry you will deal with us and
we'll deal with the rest and and that
way they were much more happy to do it
and so what we did is we gather all the
information from all the teams and we
bring them two construction plans and we
were doing the construction supervision
and the first the the first meeting
point of the place and it's this is the
Chapel of gratitude which is an open
chapel what that we did there I can I
did in obvious reference to Matthias
Garrett and what we did is a very simple
form of using the most important
Catholics symbol this is a Catholic root
which is the cross and we just did a
virtual cross with four walls that we
uplifted in there in the landscape and
creating an open chapel that also can
become a reference point and this is
what the government wanted to first have
a reference point in the area so people
can spot the start but also can be part
of the route no so this is the first
spot and the second one is up there in
the
so the route goes around here and
arrives there and and the second point
is a critic with a column done by
christen gantenbainne but what they did
it was just a reference point but at the
end the space also surprisingly has an
interior very spiritual space the next
point you encounter through the route is
this wall done by AI weiwei
which is just the world that takes you
into the mountain and to the landscape
in a very pretty way obviously now has
become Chinese wall
that's the name of it and then at this
this you encounter it but some of the
points you really see them from behind
from far and there are eight stops where
they have like these service areas done
by Emiliano Godoy and a interior
designer or eight shelters that now
they're built to that they they are this
brick structure that a the ideas that
they become flexible in terms of how the
shape of those face is because the the
the sights are very different but they
just become one open space that allows
ventilation and natural light to come in
very easy so they become and we decided
to put them next to the little Bilitis
so they can service for different
purposes while the route is not passing
we also did these open tapper that falls
these two walls that falls together and
create these open skies five space or
the structure by HHF that has become
obviously the playground of these little
kids that live around the structure from
Alejandro Aravena is a this structure
that just lands in the in the highest
part of the of the route and it's very
ironically a very creative very urban
like space when you are in it but it
actually encompasses the beautiful
landscape and the beautiful forest from
behind and people are really taking
appropriation of these space the last
point you encounter when you first to
arrive to the to the church with the
Virgin of the Rose the Rose Marie is
that the
people venerate is this circle that just
encircles the landscape tone by Derek
telecom and and it's just a simple wall
that encircles the landscape I just
wanted to finish with the our last
project that we just got two weeks ago
the permission to build it it's a house
in Spain and our main idea was to use
the the three conditions that our site
has it's a house for this project named
solo houses which I don't know if you
know but they're several young firms
doing a different house pets of an Eric
house and already did one studio Mumbai
office sooo Fujimoto John Storm ugly
they're all doing a house here and and
what our house is is that it's taking
advantage of the three conditions of the
flat part of our site which just has a
view of the of the olive trees that is
there also it leaves off to and to get
the view of the of the whole valley of
the surrounding and also goes down to
the little creek that it's in our side
to have ate that space our idea was to
bring the pyramids back to Spain and to
live there the existing tried to get
brewing and to concrete back thank you
very much with this I end up and I open
for questions if there are
Thank You Tatiana wonderful work and
wonderful explanation of the work
welcome questions we welcome questions
from our visitors and from our students
alike are there questions for our
speaker yes so we will bring a mic
what is the work they do it you know
influence your practice I didn't speak
any about it sorry but I am really now
we're working in in a lot of social
housing projects and very I've been very
political since many years about it the
police in Mexico about the production of
social housing which is more at the
workers housing it's very very bad it's
producing a horrible things and places
for literally many millions of people
living in out in incredible places and
cannot even describe them and and so
I've been very political about it I
finally arrived to meet someone in the
in the government that has has a
conscience of him and that's a former
student here in at Yale by terms it's
Carlos ADEA and so ten years ago before
he was in in there I was starting to go
into the displays the federal agency
that produces the houses in Mexico to to
try to change something and to be very
insisting and changing the way it's done
and for in the beginning they they do
things that they never thought to be
inhabited there are thought to be a
product of an economy no and and I think
that I've been working to to get that
change now is changing not obviously
because of me but because they realize
that this is a big thing that it's going
to be a big social problem if they don't
solve it not only a financial one
because people is abandoning the
places because they're horrible but it's
gonna be a social problem as well
because these people are insane and
they're really unhealthy and and finally
I encounter Carlos and I am working in a
several projects with him and I thought
that in the school we could look at that
something that it still is not being
looked at because right now if people is
really worried I was in the beginning to
stop this to be going on and then how to
do how to not do them and do things
better and so right now there are a lot
of policies on stopping them and
building better things but they're not
looking into what is going to happen
through the things that they already
built and that they're filled with
people I mean they're getting abandoned
little by little some of them have up to
40 to 50 percent of abandonment these
units which are units that range from
2000 but to till 20,000 units houses of
houses so I thought that it was
interesting and we in in in the
university could look with the students
at these places that I didn't have it
and that they are being abandoned little
and make proposals on what they could be
and then I proposed this to sevillio and
the former student and he decided to
support the studio because he thought it
was very interesting and to publish it
as a book so really people in Mexico
realized that there is also a big job to
do on and trying to think what it's
going to happen to what they already did
so that's the studio other questions or
I was so clear it was so terribly bad
Brendan Buck has a question
Tatyana thank thanks for the lecture I
think the simplicity and clarity of the
projects are very clear and as you said
maybe in reaction to the parametric
environment that you were educated and I
wonder if there's a little bit of a
holdover or something that you did take
with you from that which is
the interest in geometry and cellularity
it seems like all of the buildings are
made up of parts that are carefully
aligned or misaligned I wonder if that's
a conscious strategy or something that
you think is more intuitive and an
aesthetic where do you think that comes
from it's a little bit of everything I a
conscious strategy as I said came when I
when I saw the house of Gabriele Orozco
and I decided that I could start with
working with geometry and then make
spaces and take geometry to the limit
and make spaces that were really what I
want them to be no an architecture that
I believed through it needs to be
functioned but I also believe that
architecture needs to be aesthetic
because I think aesthetic also gives
something to our lives so I I
intuitively started I know I definitely
consciously started working with
geometric forms and then intuitively
intersecting them with what I feel they
could give to to the space you know the
these moves or these or these twists or
these extreme the use of the geometry at
some points could give to the space no
so it's a little bit of both
there's another question Peggy
Michael can wait wait the mic will come
down the part of your work that really
requires and background be stirs you
know with with the affordable housing
and you know you're saying you're going
out and really finding out what the
people want as well as for the the route
that you're organizing all of the other
architects for and kind of finding out
what each place wanted needed with the
government that kind of research which
isn't traditionally design stuff which
we're trying to do how do you staff up
for that or how do you actually manage
that part of information gathering in
your office or connections with other
agencies I'm curious how you do that
that's a very important part in our
process I think our architecture comes
exactly from there from the idea we get
after doing all these analysis and in
different projects what I do is I invite
different peoples who collaborate I
believe totally believe in collaboration
and I invite some projects is sharing it
with different colleagues architects but
many of them their way I invite for
example in the funeral house we invited
a philosopher to started working with us
and I will tell a little story about it
because when we invited the philosopher
we were into the to the death idea and
starting to study death in many ways and
we're speaking about hydaburg and
speaking about that and then he became
he came and he said guys this project
isn't about death is about the living
people that are living a boring moment
but it's not about death and that was
very important collaboration and but
that's a that's just a funny story to
say that I truly believe in
collaborations and I invite different
people like that I think that we need
them to compliment our mind to
understand the situation so in the case
of the house of the Hickock house around
earth house the the contractor became
our our most important called our later
because that was the first guy we met
and he made us understand the use of the
material he made us understand how we
could build it into budget and how then
true therefore start designing it or in
the Botanical Garden we were really a
group including the lay the ecologist of
landscape the Patrick sharpeners a
curator but also the the government
representatives the the businessman and
the people from the garden who were
designing how to take the direction of
the garden too so I truly believe that
the projects needs more inputs I think
that right now architecture is
impossible to be solved by one single
mind I think that architecture
right now it's about collaboration and
we architects probably can be the
translator to that into in space when we
need the input and the information of
many many many disciplines and as the
world's specialize much more and more I
think we even have more opportunities to
get these people around us to to respond
into the best way we can for a foreign
project there's a question in the back
hold on we'll get a microphone for you
how do you believe that your work with
or your response to low income housing
and finding out what the needs of the
people are reflects the need for
architects to be involved in disaster
relief in the sense that that's a
portion of a population that gets
ignored I think by design how you know
disaster homes are just a disaster
relief is just deployed as opposed to
the architect being present and relaying
that information yeah I actually we
didn't also a other project for six
hundred families that lost their house
because of a mud slide and and we did a
project to relocate these six hundred
families that I didn't show and but I
think that it's very important I think
as in in the society at least in my
society architects we are relegated
because they think we only give
aesthetical solutions but actually we
can give a lot of good things and good
input to to these situations not only
social housing but also like emergency
reliefs in order to create things that
are more we're trained to do that more
efficient more fast and and definitely
much better now we're trying to
understand where is the best place to
put a window
is the most efficient place to put a
window where at least is that's what the
what the architecture curricula is right
now no I don't know if everybody
understands it but I think that that in
society is really we're kind of
relegated because of that because they
think we bring more expensive solutions
we bring definitely an ego trip to the
to the to the place to the plate and
that we don't we I mean why would we
hire an architect if we can do it faster
ourselves but actually I think that it's
both parts the fault it I think out as
well we architects don't presents
ourselves to work for those those topics
no and I think we have to force
ourselves a little bit to to force
society to understand that we can give
that solutions there's another question
thank you this maybe is a bit more of a
personal question but you seem to have
such an a strong respect and passion for
your country and for your culture as
varied as it is and I just wonder as a
younger or potentially a young architect
myself has that always been important to
you or is that something that you've
come back to or just how has that how
have you evolved that passion I think it
was always important I my family comes
from Spain so I my my father's family so
I was born and raised in Mexico and I
think I was born and raised as loving my
country the place where they were taking
from their country that expelled them
from Spain after the worst so they
learned they taught me to love this
place and definitely was something that
it was there but as I said when I
started studying I I was taught it I was
taught to erase all types of history
that I had in my mind all type of
historical references not only from
Mexico from the world mainly modernist
architecture for sure and to look out
more into this globalized world that
started to be global and become more
more and more connected and to start
looking at architecture that was a
parametric architecture no and and when
I started working I started like
struggling with these that idea that I
was what my education was and what was
my reality my personal reality as I said
I was not very technological me myself
because I was never and it's not that no
one in the countries there are many
people in the country that are but I
wasn't and in also because I felt that I
was missing something I was living in
the center of the city always I was
always very interested I had family
architects building in the modern times
very so I was living in this kind of
buildings and I was living with this
architectural earnest
was released it was really not something
was missing and then I realized I needed
to go back and to understand modern
architecture and to understand a little
bit of the history of our architecture
that I live with that I grew up with and
then things became much more clear for
me so another question I think I was a
beautiful answer that's all this has
been other questions for the vendee but
in the audience and I thank our speaker
I think for a wonderful talk thank you